We'll create a new Pod
name secure monolith.
Secure monolith secures
access to the monolith
container using nginx which will serve
as the reverse proxy serving HTTPS.
The nginx container will be deployed
in the same Pod as a monolith container
because it's tightly coupled.
Before we can use the nginx
container to survey HTTP traffic,
we'll need some TLS certificate.
In this tutorial,
we'll store a set of self-signed TLS
certificates in kubernetes as secrets.
Then we won't dive into all the details
here, but we want to be secure.
So we'll need some certs,
let's look at the certs we have for
this particular application.
The cert.pem and
the key.pem files will be used to
secure traffic on a monolith server.
And the ca.pem will be used by
HTTP clients as a CA to trust.
Since the certs being used by
the monolith server were signed by
the CA represented by ca.pem,
HTTP clients that trust ca.pem
will be able to validate the SSL
connection to the Malware Server.
Next we'll use QCTL to
cure rate the TLS cert
secret from the TLS certificates
stored out of the TLS directory.
kubectl will create a key for
each file in the TLS directory
under the TLS cert secret book.
Use the kubectl describe
command to verify this.
The secure monolith pod requires
an nginx config to handle the secure
reverse proxy.
Let's review the nginx
configuration file that does this.
The proxy.conf configuration file
causes nginx to listen on port 443.
For secure connections and
proxy traffic to localhost
on port 80 where the monolithic
container is listening.
This works because the nginx
on monolithic containers,
sharing network namespace
while running in the same pod.
Next, we need to create a configmap
entry for the proxy.com
nginx configuration file using
the kubectl create config map command.
Use the kubectl describe
config map command
to get more details about
the nginx-proxy-conf config map entry.
At this point we're ready to attach
the nginx configuration files and
tailor certificates for
the secure monolith Pod.